[Musique]
non
nous sommes à l'inauguration du rucher
de le paix à paris saclay rush et qui
est derrière nous dans le cadre du
programme abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement
l'unaf donc l'union nationale de
l'apiculture française c'est un syndicat
qui comprend vingt mille salariés et
environ 500000 ruche un des principaux
syndicats français unaf a développé en
2005 le programme abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement suite tous les profs de
mortalité des abeilles est dans le but
de sensibiliser le public de leur
apprendre également le fonctionnement
d'une ruche la vie de la ruche la vie de
l'abeille est de faire en sorte de
sensibiliser la population et on peut
dire que l'objectif aujourd'hui est
atteint là il ya de la communication qui
est mise en place
je trouve très intéressant parce qu'il
ya donc un apiculteur référent qui va se
charger de la gestion des ruches ce qui
est très intéressant je trouve c'est que
semble qu'il ya des étudiants qui sont
intéressés qui vont gérer les ruches
pour le moment c'est peut-être pas très
structuré mais visiblement ça va se
mettre en place et au mois de juin 2018
il y aura les apidays alors les happy
days c'est des journées qui sont
importantes puisque c'est des journées
sont organisées de façon à mettre en
place des ateliers ludiques pédagogiques
et d'aller à la rencontre des personnes
je trouve intéressant quand même le
l'endroit où était déposé les ruches
parce qu'en fait ça correspond aussi à
une attention politique je pense que le
pea en tant qu'aménageur un rôle
important à jouer en matière de
biodiversité faire attention
la trame verte la trame bleue et bat
aussi aux espèces qu'on a m parce que là
ils sont vraiment en plein aménagement
qu'on est si ceci possible donc des
arbres mellifères des plantes mellifères
de façon à favoriser la biodiversité
parce qu'en fait les abeilles a laissé
un problème qu'elles ont également c'est
que ce qu'il faut qu'elles trouvent
allongés et que si on met que des
plantes qui n'apportent rien au niveau
nectar ça n'avance pas grand chose donc
là là
liziard c'est une zone qui est conçu
aussi et qui aura un intérêt écologique
et pour la biodiversité
[Musique]